Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. This is day 19.
We're almost halfway through. So go grab your workbook or
download one at 40daysofholiness.com. Today we are in Romans.
All right, the Book of Romans, chapter six.
How many of you have heard of Juneteenth?
It's a holiday that's rightly celebrated by the African American
community. Maybe you haven't heard of it, but Juneteenth is based on
June 19th, 1865. There was an announcement by the Union
Army General Gordon Granger that proclaimed freedom from slavery
in Texas. Now, President Abraham Lincoln's Emancipation
Proclamation had officially outlawed slavery in Texas two
and a half years earlier, but Union troops
advancing was what really enforced that. So it took them a while to get there.
And on the morning of Monday, June 19th, Granger arrived at
Galveston, Texas, and he and his troops marched
to the courthouse and then finally marched down to the church on
Broadway and announced that in accordance with a
proclamation from the President of the United States, all
slaves were free.
Now, the people of Texas are informed, here's what he said, they are informed that
in accordance with a proclamation from the executive of the United States, all the
slaves are free. This involves an absolute equality of
personal rights and rights of property between former masters and
slaves, and he said it involves the connection
heretofore existing between them, now becomes between
that of employer and hired labor. The freedmen are advised to remain
quietly at their present homes and work for wages.
Wow. Nearly two and a half years between when they were
legally free
and when
they recognized and it was announced to them.
We need a Juneteenth for Christians.
Some of you guys have been slaves to sin for a long time, and you
need somebody to come along and tell you
that you're free and that you were proclaimed free.
You need someone to challenge you to become who you really are.
Now in this passage in Romans 6, you're going to see something.
Indicatives is the Bible word for facts,
statement of facts. They're very heavy in the gospel.
Indicatives are these statements that says, "This is who you are." Indicatives
are the first part of salvation. In Romans 6:1 it says, "What shall
we say then? Shall we go on sinning so that grace may increase?"
That's a good question, right? Well, the next verse contains the
indicative, the fact. Number one, you are dead to
sin with Jesus. Verse two, "By no means.
We are those who have died to sin. How can we live in it any longer?
Or don't you know that all of us who were baptized into Christ Jesus
were baptized into his death?"
Fact number two, you are raised with Jesus to new life.
Look at verse four. "We were therefore buried with him
through baptism into death in order that just as Christ was raised
from the dead by the glory of the Father, we too may live
a new life. For if we have been united with him in a death
like his, we will certainly also be united with him in a
resurrection like his." Fact number three, sin's
control over your body is gone. Verse six, "For we
know that our old self was crucified with him so that the
body ruled by sin might be done away with." Don't miss that.
It's a fact, it's an indicative, that we should no longer be
slaves to sin because anyone who has died has been set free from sin.
Now we've done three facts, right? Three indicatives.
And now it's going to change to imperatives, right?
Arise to become, to rise up and become who you
really are in the Lord.
Here's what it says. First one is a second moment of faith, trusting God's
salvation to be full. Verse 11, "In the same way, count
yourselves dead to sin, but alive to God in Christ
Jesus." Now, count yourselves is an accounting term.
It's like write it down and take account of what is.
So he's going to give you a second call now, an imperative,
a command to rise up and become who you are.
Second call is this, a second rejection of sin.
This time, not in repentance for dead works, but in rejection
of its corrupting influence. Verse 12, "Therefore, do not let sin
reign in your mortal body so that you obey its evil
desires."
You guys hear that? Now he moves to a third call, a second moment of surrender.
This time, not as a sinner surrendering rebellion, but as a
holy person surrendering your holy body for holiness. All right.
Verse 13, "Do not offer any parts of yourself to sin as an instrument of
wickedness. But rather, offer yourselves to God as those who have
been brought from death to life, and offer every
part of yourself to him as an instrument of righteousness."
Verse 14, "For sin shall no longer be your master because
you are not under the law, but under grace." Now I want you to remember
this next statement, all right?
Truth is only a threat to the
keepers of the chains.
The truth I'm telling you today about who you are in Jesus is not a threat to you.
It's a threat to sin and Satan, who have kept you
captive to sin by imaginary chains.
The only person that stands to lose if you surrender your self life and believe
the truth, take account of what is, that you're free from sin, is Satan.
So becoming who you are, like in the great stories, like Aragorn in "The Lord of
the Rings," "From the ashes of fire shall be woken,
renewed shall be blade that was broken, the crownless again shall be king."
Right? From J.R.R. Tolkien's book.
It's a call to become who you really are.
If you don't,
who will?
So the metaphor we're dealing with today is reaching that moment in
time where you reach out and seize and become who you really are. Dr.
Alan Brown has a really neat illustration that I think is appropriate here.
He tells a story about, imagine a dead uncle,
that you get a letter from a lawyer saying that you have an uncle that has died you
didn't know about. And you go
to where the lawyer's office is, and he reads the will to you, and it turns out
you're a millionaire. He's left you this box, and it's full of
$100 bills, a million dollars worth of $100 bills.
So you grab that thing, and it's a box, a very fancy,
ornate box, and it's got three keyholes on the front.
And the lawyer hands you a chain and says, "I want you to put this around your neck
or something and wear it maybe underneath your shirt.
You don't want this to be public. And I want you to
understand that there's three locks, and these three keys fit each one of the
locks, and so you'll need those three keys to be able to open it up."
So you walk out of there with that box under your arm,
and you're a millionaire. It's the facts. It's who you are.
Now, here's the thing. If you go down to the car lot
and you say, "I'd like to buy a car. I'm a millionaire." The guy
says, "Wow. Well, that's fantastic.
Good for you. Which car are you looking at?" You say, "I want that
one right there. I want all the options.
I want the fanciest one you've got."
And then he says-- You know what's coming, right?
He says, "I'm going to need to see the cash."
Now, positionally, you're a millionaire. It is true of you.
That is who you are.
But you're going to have to take out the three keys, and you're going to have
to unlock the three locks, and you're going to have to appropriate
the riches that truly are already yours.
And in the same way, this passage in Romans 6 tells
us who we really are.
It tells us the imperative. This is who you are in Jesus.
But you're going to have to make a decision.
You're going to have to make a decision to become who you
are, to rise up and grasp the riches and
unlock. You're going to need this second moment of faith he's
talking about, faith to trust God that you really are free from sin, and you're not
a slave to it any longer.
Another key to open the
box is a second moment of surrender.
Not yielding a rebellion against God,
but yielding a holy body that is His, rightfully so.
There's a third
key, and that is a second rejection of sin.
Not in
dead works and sins that I'm actively committing, but
instead, a rejection of the corrupting influence of sin
in my heart and life.
Why don't you take control of that today? Why don't you do that?
Why don't you make the decision that I'm not going to just sit here and
relax into an average Christian life where I pretty much
fall into sin, and then I repent at night. No.
Instead, let's open the box. Let's appropriate the
riches. Let's become who you really are.
That's today's metaphor. I'll see you tomorrow.